Uh, okay. So now the move into, um, uh,
the 19th century,
it's unclear how long
these 19th century lasted,
whether it lasted from 70
and 89 until 1914 or 1815.
[inaudible] 14.
Right.
But it was a relatively
long century. Uh, and yeah,
John Stuart Mill was already
20th century, but it, Karl Marx,
we get into the middle of it,
right? He was born and, um, 18,
18 and died in 83. Uh, um,
and I tried to find a picture of Mars,
what you may have, may not have seen,
uh, when he was still a quite a
good looking guy. All right. So,
um,
a few verses about his family background.
His father, Carl Heinrich, I don't know,
Marx himself was born in
1918 in three or Germany.
And his father was Heinrich marks,
uh, who was actually a lawyer,
quite a successful lawyer. Uh, but he
was very much a man of enlightenment.
He liked Voltaire, um, and, uh, uh,
brought marks up in the spirit
of liberalism and enlightenment,
Voltaire and Russo and, uh,
uh, John Stuart Mill. Uh,
these were the guiding lights of the time.
The paternal grandfather was Mark's Levy.
It was a red by off three air,
but he died early and before
cavas born. And in fact, a,
his father converted to Lutheranism.
It did not matter much.
He was not really religious. He was a, uh,
quite secular and Marx. Karl
Marx brought up and, uh,
uh, uh, a secular family.
So I found you a picture
of cheer in the 19,
early 19th century.
If you look hard,
you'll probably see some where
young Karl of walking around,
right shopping in the
marketplace of chair,
um, or it is education.
Uh, he attended of course,
high school in Chair,
then 35.
He was admitted to the University of Bonn,
but he a,
he studied the Greek and
Roman mythology and history.
Um,
uh,
already became involved
in student politics about,
he really was born in born and was
attracted to go to Berlin of each at that
time. His big bet was becoming
a fascinating place. Um,
and uh, he was attending the
lectures. Uh, Bruno Bauer.
Uh, Bruno Bauer was a disciple
of Gower. Cagle, um, uh,
bower belonged to a group of philosophers
who called themselves the young k
galleons.
They were the cross of their time and
marsh already wanted to be a radical.
He just did not know what kind
of radical he VOB or should be.
Um, in fact, he received his degree
from the University of Vienna.
I think I cracked or that it is joke in
the introductory lecture, they fails,
assume bluntly.
It was easier to get a degree
from Vienna then their lien.
And Mark's was more interested already
in philosophy and radicalism or than
legal studies. Uh, but
he got his degree. Hell,
so he his here as Gauher Cagle uh,
uh,
one of the most important philosophers
of the 18th and 19th century.
Um, um, uh, he was a German philosopher.
Um, and ivy, we'll talk more when
we get into Mark's owner work.
Uh,
he basically saw human history as
the unfolding of human consciousness.
Um, and uh, um,
he also characterize the human
condition as in the state of alienation,
um,
in which a subject and object,
we are separated from each other.
These are big words,
you will get comfortable with it as I'm
lecturing and marks because this is very
important for he galleon philosophy.
Also a for Marxism rather distinction
that there is the subject you itself,
right who are observing and the object
the others or the material Virg upon
which you are there.
Flecting that is also another big
word you will learn in the next door.
Three lectures,
the verb of totality.
Totality means that subject and
object are together in one unity.
There's what is meant to
be a totality. Now, um, uh,
he goes idea of Oz.
That subject and object became separated
and the separation of subject from
object,
then there is seen as weird
outside after the subject as a,
a separate object. Uh, um,
that is the state of alienation.
Alien,
right to be a stranger danger in the world
because what is around you looks like
strange as different from you,
right?
That's what he meant by alienation.
Uh,
but you know,
uh,
human consciousness is increasing
and as consciousness is increasing,
uh, a, you've overcome the separation
of subject and objects. There are,
I'm sure that if is not
clear for the time being,
but Vivian laboring ground this in
more detail, uh, with mark sent,
hopefully if you become little more clear,
Bruno Bauer,
he is this charismatic lecturer,
the young Kid Galliano who's lectures
march at 10 did and that is no Marx and
Marxism beside Bruno Bauer do most of
his work is vitriolic criticism of Bruno
Bauer. Uh, well, Marxists
was quite a vitriolic guy.
He liked to use over 80 the
language. Okay. Finally.
It's very beautiful. The language he's
using. Uh, occasionally, uh, this is, uh,
pretty, uh, our trajene outraging okay.
But about Bauer and the left
he galleons. Um, um, uh,
um, as I said, you know, he
kind of, uh, [inaudible], uh,
he's a, uh, a Hagar
disciple about, um, uh, um,
he cashed to move beyond
Haig island, offer, um, uh,
critical theory of Hagar and
the he galleon system itself.
Um, uh, these guys, the
young kid galleons, uh,
uh,
bower and his brother and address like
fire buff called themselves the critical
critics.
This is a term which comes
Sapian Mark's work sometimes,
ironically, usually. Why was it so?
Because he got a is seen
in modern philosophy as the
founding father of critical
theory.
You may have heard the word
if you studied philosophy,
I'm sure you have heard the word.
What is critical theory?
I could,
the essence of critical theory is
that in beliefs that the major task or
philosophy to subject human
consciousness to critical scrutiny.
Now there is some discrepancy between
a human consciousness and the human
condition,
right?
Our consciousness does not
reflect properly the human
condition and therefore we
have to criticize consciousness
and get the right consciousness.
A Val who is actually the
first of critical theories.
There is some controversy about this
that are some people who actually named
Emmanuel Kant,
the German philosopher as the first of
critical theorist con to me then very
interesting distinction
between uh, uh, uh,
being get andZ and Dinga forsee things
in themselves and things for themselves
and Vernoff important contact
idea of us that all the ideas,
what we have in our mind are things for
themselves and they do not to the word
that around us,
the Verdun around us is so rich that
the concepts what we develop cannot
completely fit therefore, in
the act of cognition, right?
When we try to understand something,
these select from the world stuff,
which is important for us.
This is where it thinks for
themselves, right? We select, uh,
in the process of cognition,
of learning from the world
elements but is useful for us.
So I mean in some ways already count
as suggested that there is something
problematic with the human consciousness,
right?
We have to subject this human
consciousness to critical
scrutiny and to be over
there that the inner exhausted,
the richness of the world and reality
cannot be ever captured by the human mind.
Now, uh, others do.
Seriously girl Cagle as the real critical
theorist because now the central point
is alienation, right? He in the central
point is that this is a big problem.
And unlike, uh, Kahn who was an agnostic,
he did not think we ever can develop
concepts which capture the world,
right? He got to believe that if
you guys, you learn my philosophy,
you there'd be alright, right? Then
you'll all over camelia nation. You've,
you'll get the appropriate consciousness.
Read my worry. That was in, uh, you know,
I'm too simplified to a
grade year. So anyway, uh,
he was seen as a kind of,
um, critical theorist.
Now the young kid galleons where the
critiques of the critique, right?
They wanted to apply.
He goes,
critical method on Hagers theory.
They said,
why on Earth Georg,
uh,
uncle Darryl or griped believes
that his theory is the right one.
Why don't we subject this system
itself to the same critical scrutiny.
But he goes suggest everything should
be subjected to critical scrutiny.
That is really the
fundamental line of argument,
but greatly influenced Marx.
Marx is in many respects,
a critical critique.
Now,
this is another young kid galleon
Ludwig Feuerbach who had another very
important impact on the marks.
Uh,
Feuerbach caught his approach.
Naturalism,
this is a term but marks the young
Marx also used for a vile to describe
himself.
I think most of you in this room of
would think that Mark's was a materialist
and their venture,
any marks use the term materialism and
more specifically historical materialism
to describe what he was doing.
But in his early work,
he was shying away from materialism.
Uh,
and he used the term naturalism and
natural is Maria the meant that you do not
underestimate the important
of consciousness in spirit.
Just in the introduction
with consciousness and
spirit and the nature itself,
you pay more attention to nature.
Now,
firebox most important book,
I don't think it is in English.
That's the reason the Kristen plume
the essence of Christianity. Um,
he also suggested that
rather than God creating man,
men created the idea of God
and they created the idea
of God is actually not all
that far from Grunow bower, just a
more radical position. Right. Um,
um,
because it found that to project
the desperation of alienation,
uh, into the idea of
God. Uh, so I mean, uh,
via, uh, um, uh,
so to say Bauer was not ready to drew the,
if I may use this term,
the ontological conclusions of his
criticism of Hagar Feuerbach vent into
ontology, right? Ontology
means the origins of things.
And he believed right, that
in fact, the spiritual,
the is a reflection right,
of humans as such.
That's why he called this naturalism
as this thing from idealism.
And Vivian,
talk about the distinction
between idealism and
materialism or ideal isn't as an
a church naturalism,
which is very important for Marxism and
has been an important distinction in
philosophy in the 19th and
earliest strengths. Uh,
20th century. I don't think
in the last, you know,
50 or a hundred years, uh,
that, you know, in philosophy,
discuss too much ice though.
I mean,
I don't think it describes a useless
distinction who are idealists and who are
materialists and well Vva.
We'll talk very briefly
about this. Uh, um,
let me just foreshadow,
right? I you know what,
you are an idealist when you think that
the material of word is coming from an
an idea, right? If you
believe that there was a, um,
a transcendental being like God and this
transcendental being by its act of veal
created the word and created humans,
then you add an idealist.
If you believe rather the ideas
are explaining human behavior,
then you add an idealist.
Materialists are the ones who start from
the material conditions and tried to
explain the ideas from the
material conditions. Uh,
right.
Fire back mid is a provocative statement
that we invented God rather than God
creating us mark schools
further and he will say, well,
you have ideas on your head.
I can tell you why you have these ideas.
Then I look at your material
conditions and he will later on say,
when I understand your position in the
class structure and I understand you
would economic interest,
then I view,
be able to tell you why you
think the way you think, right?
This is the material is separate or
should I then you explain ideas from the
material conditions that versus
the other way around. Um,
and this comes from, uh, uh, um, uh,
Feuerbach Feuerbach inspiration,
right?
So you bring together are the critical
theory of Hagar and a young kid galleons
radical critique, critical theory
and natural isn't, uh, for,
uh, Feuerbach eventually pushing it
further and say, let's not fool that out.
And it, it is, material is more,
right. Okay. Now what about,
let's continue with the lifer. Um, 42, uh,
he moves to colonia the city of
Catalonia and becomes a journalist for
[inaudible] side to him.
Eventually even becomes
the editor of this journal.
And what he's writing is
just liberal journalism.
He's not a radical yet, is
a bourgeois liberal. Uh,
he is writing articles about,
you know,
the freedom of the press
and civil liberties.
He's writing staffer about to John
Stuart Mill would not object to at all.
Right. And then 43, he marries a,
I again, correct this joke
before, after a long engagements,
uh, Yanni phone invest Farlane
who comes from, uh, uh,
uh, uh, you know, a normal family,
a very high class family,
not, not Jewish family,
a high class family here. Here
is the picture of, of them.
Too many. It was going fast, right?
Um, uh, he was running into some,
uh, uh, political troubles very soon. Uh,
now the veal very quickly see some
extra ordinary years in March,
intellectual development, 1843, 44,
45,
just three years is quite extra ordinary.
What is happening in Mark's mind
and how far he goes or that in 43,
he is beginning to some very
important pieces of work.
I've, you're talking about them in a
minute. [inaudible] get to Mark's work,
Bonnie Scott,
our contribution to the critique of
Hegel's philosophy of the state or fit a
fit,
he goes philosophy of law or
writes it translated differently.
Um,
and then he's writing a very provocative
essay on the Jewish question in which
he beginning to distinguish himself
from the young key galleons, uh,
was of the speed of bcs,
especially on the Jewish question,
are an unacceptable to the German
police and political establishment.
So he had to leave Germany and he escapes
and he moves Sperry's and here it is
totaled. He Arriva No,
that's where he lived.
And that's where Marc Serota and his
extra ordinary unpublished manuscript for
this God,
the Paris manuscript of 1844 what form,
which you have read something.
And some of them are the jewel
pieces of social science literature.
Some of them is impenetrable,
but some of them is quite penetrable
and still blows people's mind.
Okay. 1844 in Paris. He, um, uh,
abandoned this book,
the critique of Hagar,
but he wrote an introduction, and
I will talk about this later. Uh,
this in many ways is quite an
extraordinary piece of work.
It's a wonderful piece of poor poetry.
Um,
and he sort of beginning
to lay out his philosophy.
And then in the summer of 44,
he completes a high heel,
not doesn't complete. He abandons
the Paris manuscripts. Um,
and for good reasons, and we
will talk about this, why, uh,
he never published it and never
finished it though. I mean,
it is quite,
quite a brilliant piece
and he needs a young man,
Reddick angles. Um, uh,
just 24 years of age and became lifelong
friends and they beginning to work
together. They are writing
this book, the Holy Family.
I strongly recommend you do not read it.
I have read it a number of
times and suffered a lot,
so I want to save you from suffering.
But there are some very important things
in the holiday family. Just uh, uh,
the price you have to pay to
find the jaw is very high.
Okay. Uh, and then they write
many other things together. Uh,
the communist manifesto, the, they ride
together, the German ideology, they,
they ride together and many other things.
Mangoes wasn't brilliant
mind. Uh, in fact,
he was a much more clearer
analytic mind then. Karl Marx,
and he had had a much better sense
of empirical reality than March.
March was a bit of an abstract guy,
but Marx was really the genius,
right? Um, uh, Fredrick Kango swells
just a kind of year professor, you know,
that Karl Marx was a sort
of fact genius. Really, uh,
45. Well, uh, even in Paris, the on,
on bare above what they are doing.
So they kicked out from Paris
and then they go to Brussels.
And here his angles when they met, uh, uh,
uh, there is, uh, you continue
to work a big change in,
in 1945,
there is some people say
the epistemological break
until 45 until the Paris
manuscript, uh, uh, marks is
still in some ways I hear galleon.
Um,
uh,
now he's changing and he's becoming a
list and he coins the term historical
materialism to describe his, uh, position.
One important piece is that exists on
a foyer bar. I make you to read that.
I think it is a fantastic piece of
work, yet again, did not publish it.
And I will explain to you
why though it is brilliant,
why he shied away and did not publish it.
It's intention with the main message
about he tries to get through. Um,
and then 45,
five 46 together with angles they right
again and other unfinished manuscript
which was published only in 1904,
uh,
and even in 1904, only partially, um,
the German ideology. Um, and again, uh,
there are some extra ordinary pieces in
this incomplete manuscripts then comes
to year of revolutions.
February 22,
24 and 48,
a violent revolution in France.
They sit down with angles and Viseon Ivy,
they write the manifesto
of the Communist Party.
They just tell about the revolution
should be doing. Uh, well this is enough.
Bam flat,
a pamphlet with a lot of
disturbing statements,
but the pamphlet with
some very insightful,
very important social analysis as well.
Uh,
a piece of work which cannot
be ignored if can be hated.
Uh, it was loved by many,
but usually now it is hated.
But even if he hate you,
hate it or love it,
you better read it and you pay
attention to some of the very important
statements. And what is extra ordinary?
This is a pretty long manuscript.
They've were writing like crazy.
I mean I think I'm a fast writer,
but I could not do it in a week. Um, uh,
reasonably polic punish a polished,
especially in comparison
with these other very,
now he's expat from grasses,
but he moves to the evolutionary Paris
right on march the fifth or ready bud.
That evolution continues.
Mazda thirteens Vianna
is in fire, right? Uh,
but you have to wait on it to two days
and Budapest in Hungary is in fire.
The revolution is spreading all
over in Europe. March eight,
18, it's already in Berlin bows, Vienna,
Budapest, Berlin, whole Europe is in via,
this is exactly what Max was saying.
He'd will be happening.
Why there it is happening indeed.
So Maurice and Angus returned to Germany.
Now they will carry out the
torch of that evolution.
Now he doesn't class for,
that's a picture of backbeat shirt of
some of the revolution in bat is what's
quite a bloody event. Uh, and
here is a communist manifesto,
the first edition and a February,
1848 when it was printed heart
and distributed widely. Now,
you know, when evolution doesn't
last too long, in October 48, uh,
Austria carries out a contract evolution.
Uh,
they are pressed that evolution in
Hungary. Um, November the eight,
there is a controlled evolutionary cool,
uh,
in Prussia that evolution
is a, uh, depressed.
And then December, 1848, they are,
this is not a violent country revolution,
but the French go and vote on elections.
And the elected guy whose name is Louis
Napoleon Bonaparte after as president of
France,
it was a very stupid way to vote.
Uh, Louis Napoleon Bonaparte,
whatever was the nephew of not,
not pull down. Uh, uh,
his father was Napoleon's brother,
younger brother,
and he was the king.
He was meet King of the Netherlands
until of course, Napoleon fail.
And he was out sitting, uh,
Louis Napoleon Bonaparte, um,
uh,
grew up in Switzerland in exile a,
it was not particularly
smart person, um, uh,
and cause a lot of trouble in France.
Now here he is when he was president,
later on he became right.
Um, uh, uh, emperor of France,
not Polandra hundred cured.
He renamed himself and kept
causing trouble. Yeah. Um,
now, uh, remarks, uh,
returned to Paris briefly and
was hoping, you know, the French,
eventually you will come to
their senses and oversee over,
through this jerk.
Now,
the French did not come to
them that Sam says, right? Uh,
it looks like the French occasionally
do, do, do silly political things.
Slide the Jacobins electing
Gooey, uh, uh, not,
uh, not, uh, Napoleon Bonaparte.
It was not a smart thing,
but you know that for they have to move
to London and that's where he published,
spends the rest of his life.
This is about,
he has another go at the
big book he wants to write.
It is called the ground
Resa. And Ivy, I'll ask you,
which will be a little
sweating to lead it. Uh,
but I Braum is,
I ask you to read the most readable
part of their going to sir.
So if you will have troubles
reading what I asked you to read,
remember the rest would be
much, much worse, right?
So you have to enjoy right reading it.
I think I asked you to do the to read
is extremely important to understand who
the real mark says,
right?
There are many faces of Karl Marx and
one of one article most clearly in
different on this.
Then he has finally the book,
but he overs wanted to do
the scrappy tab in 1867 a.
Then there is another revolution
in France said the commune,
and this is a real proletarian revolution.
They're very much following what Marx
and Engels wrote in the communist
manifesto that are a few instances
in history when two people can claim,
we wrote it down and hear the masters
put it into action. They did it in,
in France and then order the NCC for
marks created a political organization,
what he called international
international diverse organization.
Eventually we refer to this as the first
international with a Russian anarchist
whose name is Bakunin a 70 Vonda is this
proletarian revolution inspired by the
communist manifesto. They proclaim
our communal, uh, in Paris.
It's not all that different from
Soviet Russia or malware is China.
The same ideas does not last too long,
right?
In two weeks it is suppressed
and overthrown. Um,
and uh, Mark's dissolves
the international, uh,
that is a big fight between
Bakunin and Marx. Uh,
I think in this big fight mark Bakunin
who is actually not very smart,
but in the,
I think in the debate Baconian is quite
right about Mark's statism or too much
believe in Marx about the government
should do and Baconian is bottom up,
right? Uh, Baconian is an anarchist.
He believes in the ordinary people and
he wants to get read of the State rather
than doing stop by the
state. Uh, anyway, they,
they solved the first international.
Now Betty,
the defeat of Paris commune
was a very ugly affair. Uh,
people who were mass murdered, we,
south tria not very nice stuff.
Do, I mean the Paris
commune, of course, you know,
if you're as the anarchy staff saying
now if you want to have scrambled eggs,
you have to break a
couple of eggs, right? Uh,
so if you have a revolution,
occasionally you shoot. All right, well,
it was shooting on the canoe.
There was a lot of shooting
after the you right. Uh,
well after the commune, uh, uh, we
have a conservative epoch in Europe.
Um, Bismarck in Germany, right?
The iron chancellor,
Queen Victoria, right?
Uh,
uh,
ethical conservative is a Kaiser
France Joseph for the Blue Down Hole,
right? So operetta uh,
but very conservative guy.
I have so many nice anecdotes about him.
Too bad the course doesn't last two
semesters because I could entertain UBIT,
create stories about Kaiser Franz Joseph,
uh, big trouble. The Guy,
he primarily because the first world
war out of completely stupid action and
caused the deaths of millions of people,
uh,
in a bloody terribles cupid's war.
Well about that is no room in this
conservative time to revolution, right?
The Revolutionary Marxism,
Marx dies in desperation.
Actually,
if you read the later very,
his mind is gradually
disintegrating. Yeah. Um,
and he's buried together. We, Jenny, uh,
in London Highgate cemetery,
uh,
you probable it. It was just, um,
be some New York review of
books on Highgate cemetery.
Also names the Tom of Karl Marx.
We stands that and Marxist
goal now at postscript to the,
then all the create a second
international, uh, after his desk, uh,
and NGOs created it,
it eventually became what we call
a social democratic international.
It's still exist.
Social Democratic parties occasionally
meet on an international meeting for that
via vendor.
Democratic Corp Bharthi was
a kind of Gfk Liberal Party.
Even the American Democratic Party sent
observers to the second international
meetings,
right.
Bobby Kennedy was a kind of very
sympathetic to second international.
We're kind of considering,
should not the Democratic Party join,
right? The social democratic
international movement, 1917,
that is a communist
revolution in Russia and 1919,
they say second international.
This really sucks.
This is not about revolution.
This is about reform.
We need a real revolutionary organization.
They create the third international
communist international,
which lasts until the Second World War.
Then Russia and the Soviet Russia needs
the help of the United States to defeat
militarily, Germany. And the US said, all
right, but you dissolve the international.
So they did this, solve
the international, uh,
that is actually a force international.
I don't have time usually to talk about
this created by their own Trotsky or,
right. So that's about the life of a, um,
one of our major author Karl Marx.
And let me go on and talk
about his theory of alienation.
And I have my goodness,
12 minutes to do that though.
I could spend,
uh,
in fact the semester on
this, uh, uh, hell no.
But let me try to economize with my
time and I just very briefly run through
what is,
what is leading to the Paris manuscript
and the theory of alienation.
And I really have to talk
about alienation. So I,
you'll skip a lot of stuff
leading to the alienation.
So I said he got is the point of
departure for Marcy, theory of alienation,
but there is a kind of intellectual
project for the young Marx.
Um, as I said, he writes,
tries to write this book.
He goes a critique of Hegel's
philosophy of write this book.
He got suggested that there is a,
a,
the CVS store servants
constitute a universal class.
It is a critique of the French revolution
and the bourgeois society in which
Hagle felt the workers and the
capitalists are in athletics.
That's representing
particularistic interest and
order can be brought into this
only by civil servants,
by the government who represents
the universe of point of view.
And Mark's criticized is this a book?
Uh,
then he writes on the Jewish
question that he said, well,
the state bureaucrats are not universal,
but we need a universal standpoint. We
need universal [inaudible] emancipation.
Uh, as such, that's the point of view.
Then he writes this wonderful piece,
introduction to the critical figures
philosophy of ride. And he said,
but Julio Curry how this, uh, uh, in,
uh, you know, universal point of view.
And it is the introduction for
the first time in 44 January.
And he said the proletariat, but
people say, lie the proletariat.
Goodness Gracious.
That's when the manuscript comes here.
You said to put all that Talia because
the proletariat is the ultimate of
alienation and because they are alienated,
they have the interest to
overcome Eliana nation. Well,
I think I just have true Rushall
IBM put this stuff on the
Internet, but I really don't
have time to get into any detail.
I want to get,
uh,
in the last few minutes into the Paris
manuscripts and this is the structure of
the Paris manuscripted of 1844. You
can see the line of argument, right?
How he's developing, right.
Um, uh, his, his argument,
um,
what is really interesting from the
parish manuscript is the first manuscript,
which is 27 pages. It
is on wages, profits,
and rant and culminates
with the idea of alienation.
Uh,
again,
unfortunately I don't have more
time to work more on a, on a,
um, uh, um, uh, especially, uh,
section four is crucially important.
Now,
the second and the third
manuscripts, uh, uh,
are of lesser important.
Now the major teams,
they, each profit and renter
and private ownership,
they all culminate in alienation
is a reinterpretation of Hagle.
Uh,
alienation does not come from ideas.
It comes out of material conditions
of the nature of capitalist economy.
And as I said,
he does not have the notion of capitalism.
It comes out of the nature of
commodity producing commercial society,
right? That's where alienation
is coming from rather than ideas.
And the problem can only be solved
if you fix the problems of commodity
producing societies.
And then he identifies four
characteristics of alienation.
And I've even talked to this,
uh,
wrong alienation is from
the object of production.
The second is the alienation from the
act of production than any other nation.
From species being,
again, a very big word,
God trumps reason in German.
Uh, what, what makes us human?
What makes us distinct from animals?
That's what the notion
species being refers to.
And finally alienation from fellow man.
Well,
I have seven minutes to Labor on
this. Let me do that. Um, okay.
Um, cause I said he
reinterprets he goes alienation.
Uh, he got, wanted to overcome
alienation in thought. Um,
uh, alienation was a problem
of the state of consciousness.
Mark's wants to ground the theory
in material practices. Right?
Um, uh, and uh, then, uh,
and merge you said Ed alienation
when Labor is becoming a commodity,
right? Uh, uh, uh, uh, and
uh, uh, [inaudible], uh,
profit drive.
So he come on me that span to be
enter the stage of alienation.
Um, uh, and the, uh, private
property emerges. Well,
I just leave this section out and let me
speak to the four dimensions of Neisha
and the next six or seven minutes.
So the first point is that is um,
you know,
we are talking about commodity producing
commercial society is to put it with
Adam Smash. All right. Uh,
or Marksville call it later on.
If you take him one more
year to figure it out.
What is really the nature of
the society is talking about,
about already in the German ideology
as we voc it Tuesday or a Thursday,
he coins the term the
capitalist mode of production.
So in the capitalist mode of production
in a commodity producing society,
um, the, the object which leads,
produces labors product conference,
the Vickers as something alien,
uh,
from him as a bower Elian of the producer,
right?
Under these conditions,
this realization of labor appears as the
loss of realization of the very care in
sharp contrast with petty
commodity production.
The work of the Artism that diverse,
what you produced is
part of your own life.
You identify with the part
what you produce, right?
You are a shoemaker, you are
producing a beautiful shoe, right?
You are proud of the shoe.
You go to the church Sunday and you saw
a nice lady walking in this beautiful
shoes and you proudly say,
this is my shoe, right?
Then you are not alienated,
right?
When you are working on the production
line and you are mass producing, uh,
you know, uh, Toyota Camry, ah,
you don't know what you produce shite.
It's an alien object from you.
You put a little bit of worry,
cried into the product and the
product is not you any longer.
It is something which is alien from you.
Um,
well, uh, of course not all of our work is
national story. Aliana ate it. You know,
if you are an RF,
just if you are a scholar,
you identify the right can you
have copyright for the verdict,
what you produce. But ordinary workers
usually do not have copyrights,
you know,
they cannot license.
They're very well Dave told you
was it becomes alien from them.
That's the point or the product.
Well then you are also becoming area
and in the act of production is that
because Labor is external to the
work at our different points in this,
right? External of were
Kelly does not belong to him.
His intrinsic nature in his work,
he does not affirm himself
but denies himself,
does not really develop
itself. You know, you say,
well that's already uh,
four 45,
I have only 15 more minutes to
go and then I am free. Right?
Life begins when work ends.
Right. You can see it,
you go to the supermarket and the
cashier hardly needs, you know,
to get out of here. I was trying to buy,
uh, last night, you know, a little beer,
you know, and it was eight 45.
And the cashier said, sorry,
I cannot sell it to you.
I said, why not? I till nine
o'clock. He said he's ninth, nine.
Yet she wanted to get out of there.
Right?
So it's alienated from the
process of production, right?
And Labor is not all on 30,
but for us, right? Well for us,
not legally you can starve,
right?
But if you don't want to strong
and you want to have a place,
a roof over your head, you have to
work. So it is forced economically.
So it is not one. It is. Here
is the right. Um, uh, uh,
and uh, you were activity
belonged to somebody else.
It's somebody else, you know,
go mass you who is the boss who tells
you what to do and then you shut up.
Right? Uh, and this is why, you know,
in the act of production
you have Eliana nature.
The third one is that you are alienated
from new species being off your human
being.
And now Marx has a teary of man in nature.
What is man?
And they in natural conditions,
what makes us man as distinct from animal
that are very different answers you
can give. Uh, well, uh,
Sheeler the German poet said,
what makes us humans that the
mo how to play. All right,
pray makes us human.
Mark said,
what makes us human that via Varick labor,
that the transform the material
work to meet our human needs,
a plan in our head,
that's what makes us humans.
There are animals which kind of
work like bs, but they don't work.
Vieta plan it.
There are only humans who have an
idea of what my house, meal Beal.
And then you build a house
as you had the idea about it.
That is the essence of human beings.
And he said,
the problem is that we in a
commodity producing society,
VR alienated from Labor
but makes us human.
So we are alienated from
our very human essence.
That's the most horrifying thing for
marks in a commodity producing society.
Right? Uh, and then finally the
odd alienated from our fellow man.
This is probably the deepest, um, uh,
idea in the whole theory, right? Uh,
namely that we are beginning
to treat each others as object,
right? As we are entering the
world of commodity production,
profit maximization,
self interested individuals,
right? Maximizing utility, right?
And thinking instrumentalist
around the world, right?
What are the most less expensive means,
which gets us the cheapest to this end
than the beginning to treat each others
as instrument right?
Now he said this is the versed
alienation, which is new, right? It has,
this is very important to see
in marsh theory of alienation.
It's not a general condition of
humankind as Hagar thought it.
Alienation is emerging in modernity.
He does not have the term capitalism yet,
or the capitalist mode of production.
This is the characteristics of modernity
and modern industrial and urban life
that we are not interacting
with each other as human beings,
right?
In an all sided personal relationships,
but we tend to treat each
others as objects, right?
Between the other person
as a sex object, right? Uh,
the erotic complex relationship
is reduced to a brutal act of sex,
right?
We treat each other as an
instrument to reach an end, right?
The call, the others only then they
need that person for something.
Right?
The act out of simply self interest
in interacting with the others,
the lack compassion that we lack
love. Right. The lack sympathy. Right.
We seem, you know, he probably
did not read his Adam Smith's
care of fully enough,
right? It has not been
reading Mark Smith until 44.
This is where he's beginning to reach
Smith's very carefully around this time in
44 [inaudible] you see the point that
he's making and I think what Mark's
describes in alienation,
particularly alienation from fellow human
being is something that probably some
people in this room can respond
to and to say, well, yes,
I did experience that.
I have been treated right as an object
when I go to the admission office
occasionally. Right? Um,
an administrator like treats me like
a piece of work that a piece of paper,
right? That's when you
are alienated, right?
Then you becoming an abstract
that than a human being.
So that's in a nutshell,
the theory of alienation that has
to be will be up on the Internet,
and you may want to dig into the
whole intellectual development,
which brings you to the beak of
what he called the young Marx.
Marx.
The he galleon marks who is not a
material is less yet not a historic on
materials.
He does not have the idea of exploitation.
It does not have the idea of the
capitalist model reduction yet.
All right.